I want you to meet my protege Delaney
hello Delaney I've heard so much about
you have a seat Delaney Reynolds 16 year
old budding scientist somebody who found
out about climate change and sea level
rise and she's really engaged and she's
really interested and she wants to tell
other kids about it is it true I've
heard that you are a student of climate
change yes that is true that's very
impressive at your age I go into
classrooms and community centers and I
speak to anyone that's going to listen
about the problem
this graph shows predictions for sea
level rise and I show them real science
from IPCC reports Union of Concerned
Scientists NASA and they get it a
message of hope a message of solutions
and the surprising thing was it came
from a kid today I'm going to talk to
you guys about my passion which is
global warming and sea level rise so it
seems like that's the trend with the
youth movement it's like more and more
people accepting what's happening you
have to come together and decide whether
we want to sink or swim is there gonna
be in Miami when she grows up is she
gonna be able to raise her family here
is she gonna be able to live here what
if Miami can't be saved
will you leave if that does happen then
we either gonna have to get out or build
up but I actually have hope that that
won't happen we will be able to solve
this bomb I think we have to solve this
problem 16 years old and so filled with
promise and potential and hope have we
given you hope yes finally I found some
hope we talked about hope can we do this
and we came to the clusion that yeah we
can we just need to get kids on board
and we need to get our political leaders
on board
you